I've emailed a company and CCD in three
different people two people have said no
and one person said yes so it just shows
you just have to get to the right person
because some people might see you and
think no but then you get to the right
person and they're like wow this is
amazing I've reached out to some huge
brands that I've said to myself I'm not
going to reach out to them because why
would they want to work with me and then
I just pluck up the courage and do it
and they actually respond find the right
person get to them tell them what they
want to know these people have marketing
budgets they do actually want to push
their products and their services if you
can show them that you're going to do
that they're going to work with you